today on the matt welsh show i appeared
on dr phil to argue about gender and
pronouns with a couple of non-binary
diversity consultants and a woke college
professor we'll talk about the
experience today and watch a few of the
clips together also two of my opponents
on the stage are now complaining that i
have caused them to plunge into
depression and they're having nightmares
because of me what did i do to cause
such trauma we'll try to figure that out
and joe biden held just his second press
conference in a year it was a total
disaster as you might expect the media
gets caught in yet another fake news
scandal and a major car company goes
woke though as always it's not really
clear what they hope to accomplish by
that we'll discuss all of that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm really excited to have good ranchers
uh on board the matt walsh show this
year and uh teaming up with the daily
wire these are great guys at good
ranchers and fortunately for you good
ranchers is the exclusive meat company
of the daily wire they help you get
american meat delivered they've got 100
american steakhouse quality meat and
it's all for an affordable price over 85
percent of the grass-fed beef in stores
online is imported from overseas which
undermines american farms and ranches
and often causes them to shut down as
well if you shop good ranchers today
you're supporting american made and
you're putting the small farm back on
top plus you use my code walsh for 30
off that's the biggest first purchase
discount code good ranchers has ever
given out which means there's never been
a better time to buy support american
farms and ranches and get delicious
t-bones gourmet burgers rib eyes and
more mouth-watering cuts in the process
visit goodranchers.com walsh or use
codewall should check out to get 30 off
any one of their many boxes everything
they sell is truly top-notch and you
really have to try it so visit
goodranchers.com today to save 30 on
your new favorite steak start the year
with good ranchers american meat
delivered
for those who were able to watch it my
appearance on dr phil aired yesterday
afternoon it was my first time appearing
on television outside of fox news and
also my first time meeting with a
psychologist
some would say that i should make more
of a regular habit of it talking to a
psychologist i mean not appearing on tv
but unfortunately
not everybody was able to watch the
discussion i'm told in some market in
some markets it was sidelined by
president biden's press conference i
think we can all agree that of all the
terrible things biden has done during
his disastrous tenure preempting my dr
phil episode is by far the worst
now there's always a certain risk
inherence in walking into an environment
like this
especially with the cameras rolling of
course i knew that i would be
outnumbered on stage in front of a
hostile studio audience
and if i had been invited to speak about
a more complicated or difficult issue
one that requires you to actually be
smart
then um that would have given me pause
but the topic of the episode was gender
and pronouns which means that it's not
complicated or difficult at all
my position the correct position is
extremely simple sensible obvious and
clear
the only mistake that somebody on my
side of the issue can make
and very often people do make this
mistake
in a debate of this kind
is to make the subject seem more
complicated than it is
getting lost in the rhetorical weeds and
losing sight of the main point
that that's where the other side lives
they're out there in the weeds where
things are muddy and muddled
they like it out there they want to
obscure the main point mystifying what
is actually quite simple
as long as you refuse to be baited into
that trap and you stay on message
on the firm ground of truth and science
and common sense you can have this
conversation anywhere with anybody on
any platform in front of any audience
and you will walk away the winner every
time
and if you're a naturally argumentative
bastard like myself you'll even have fun
doing it
now that gives you an idea of my basic
strategy so now we'll watch some some
clips of a few of the most important
exchanges during the episode and we'll
see how it played out we'll begin with
the opening salvo which came several
minutes into the episode as the first
segment featured just the two non-binary
diversity consultants
spewing inane garbage unopposed and i
was backstage for that portion just
pacing back and forth listening in
horror
muttering incredulously to myself and
when it was my turn i began by
clarifying that everybody that that you
know everything that was said in the
previous segment was total nonsense and
then we dived into the pronoun question
let's watch
there should be no construct of gender
just sex you're either male or female
right and
someone feeling
in a mental emotional way
that they don't
identify
with the sex that they have
been biologically created as and
assigned at birth based on their
genitalia
if they don't feel that way that there's
no construct that describes that
experiences that well that's got nothing
to do with the reality so you can feel
however you want i mean i could sit here
and say that i feel like a tomato plant
but that doesn't mean they're actually
in those things so your your
self-perception you can have whatever
self-perception you want but you can't
expect me to take part in that
self-perception or to take part in this
kind of charade this theatrical
production
you don't get your own pronouns just
like you don't get your own prepositions
or your own your own adjectives you know
it's like if i were to tell you
my adjectives are handsome and brilliant
and no matter whenever you're talking
about me you have to describe me as
handsome and brilliant because that's
how i identify makes no sense you don't
get your own pronouns these are that's
that's that's grammar that's language so
you think it's a delusion
someone is self-delusional yeah i think
it's it's delusion it could be a mental
illness it could be it's a lot of
different things with children you know
there's also just a basic confusion that
all kids have like that's why when you
hear
when you hear someone a parent say oh my
four-year-old
son
came to me and said that i'm a girl now
and so that's what i'm gonna i'm gonna
raise him as a girl
no you're a four-year-old i have four
kids
when a four-year-old boy comes to you
and says oh i'm a girl here's a good
follow-up question
what is a girl
ask him what he means by that what do
you mean by a girl and when you ask him
that here's what he'll tell you
he will tell you what he really means is
that he he wants to do some of the
things that girls do like play with the
dollhouse or or you know he likes the
color pink that's fine play with a
dollhouse
but you're still a boy
i hope you'll respect my preferred
adjectives of course the only problem
with my adjective comparison is that
unlike pronouns adjectives are in fact
subjective
but my point was that the adjectives i
use to describe myself
are products of my self-perception i
cannot demand that others perceive me
the way that i perceive myself
my self-perception is not a joint
project shared by me and the rest of
human society for adjectives it's up to
each individual to decide which ones
they want to use to describe me and in
my case a great many people use
adjectives to describe me that i find
quite disagreeable i might feel insulted
by some of those adjectives i might lock
myself in the bathroom and weep
uncontrollably for hours because of them
i do that every day
but i cannot say that i'm being erased
or delegitimized because other people
refuse to see me the way that i see
myself
and in fact if their competing
perception
causes some sort of existential crisis
for me
it only proves that i'm not so sure of
my own self-perception and therefore i'm
in no position to criticize anybody
else's perception of me
as for pronouns there is no subjectivity
at all
it's not up to any individual including
myself to decide which ones ought to be
used that question is settled by
biological reality the point of the
pronoun is to describe that reality
just as the point of a verb like running
unless it's unless it's used
metaphorically is to convey reality if i
say that somebody is running when
they're really sitting
i've conveyed an untruth
whether because i'm confused or a liar
or both and if i call a man a she i have
also expressed it on truth whether
because i'm confused or a liar or both
or perhaps because i'm afraid of getting
yelled at if i tell the truth
so we should add coward
alongside the options of confused and
liar
in any case the pronoun question led
directly to the question the ultimate i
mean the question the ultimate and
fundamental question as far as i'm
concerned which my opponents were not
very eager to answer
that's a question i would like to throw
out to you know other members of the
panel actually because just like the
four-year-old can't answer what is a
girl
well this is one of the problems with
this left-wing gender ideology is that
no one who espouses it
can even tell you what these words mean
it's like what is a woman
can you tell me what a woman is
no i can't
because it's not for me to say i
womanhood looks different for everybody
what do you what do you define a woman
as an adult human female and what does a
female mean
uh
someone with with female reproductive
organs
okay someone who's you know here's the
thing when you're when you're female it
goes right down to your bones your dna
so that's why if someone
dies okay we could dig up their bones a
hundred years from now we have no idea
what they believed in their head but we
can tell what sex they were because it's
in it's down in it's it's ingrained in
every fiber of their being interesting
so i'm trying to understand your
definition is that a woman is someone
who is female you said right correct is
a biological female so what happens if
we have maybe someone who is female
identifies as a woman right you know
cisgender woman right as you explain as
you just explained
it maybe doesn't have the ability to
reproduce
maybe doesn't have those organs that
you're talking about that are
reproductive organs i have answered the
question
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a womanhood is something that just as
ethan explained i cannot define because
i am not myself
so what did you mean when you said trans
women are women if you don't know what
it means
so here's the thing so i do not define
what a woman is because i do not
identify as a woman womanhood is
something that is an umbrella term it
includes people that describes what
people who identify as a woman i
identify as what as a woman what is that
was to each their own each woman each
man each person is going to have a
different relation with their own gender
identity and define it differently so
trans women
are women too okay
and you want to hold up
women you want to reduce men down to
maybe just their genetics our genitals
our chromosomes right that's what you're
what you want to do is that's what you
what you want to do is appropriate women
you want to appropriate womanhood okay
and turn it into basically a costume
that could be worn
now the episode continued for another 45
minutes after that but that was really
the end of the conversation i could have
gotten up and walked off the stage right
there which would have been funny um the
other side was there to argue that trans
women are women and that anyone can be a
woman if that's how they feel about
themselves and yet they could not
explain what they meant when they use
that term
trans women are women what's a woman
well who knows
the statement trans women are women
means nothing in that case
they don't know what they mean when they
say it
they don't understand their own position
game over
you notice the obscurantist tactic at
work here because the bearded gentleman
had declared in the previous segment to
the raucous applause that trans women
are women
and i asked him what he means and he
immediately hopped on the circular logic
merry-go-round rambling a bunch of hazy
gibberish about how only women can
define the word women that doesn't make
any sense because for one thing
he's not an elephant but i'm sure he can
tell me what an elephant is also even
the statement that only women can define
women
requires you to know what a woman is
otherwise how can you know who has the
right to define it and who doesn't
well the answer is that he knows who a
woman is because they're the ones who
say they're women and we know that they
are right in their claims of being women
because they're saying it and they say
they're women because they are women and
they are women because they say they're
women
around and around we go or they go
anyway
they hope to pull you onto the
merry-go-round with them making you as
dizzy and confused as they are which is
why it's important to have simple
answers
simple definitions
simple responses and you stick to them
let them twirl around and tie themselves
into knots you're standing on solid
ground
stay there
one more clip worth playing after a very
awkward commercial break where everybody
sat in silence
awkward for them anyway you know i
thought the whole situation was pretty
hilarious
we came back with a supposed gender
expert and college professor who
provoked applause from the trained seals
in the audience when she hit me with the
old why do you care so much routine
there's biological sex and then there is
gender identity part of me wants to ask
why you care so much uh because it's
really not that big of a deal oh yeah
um
i i loved it i'd love to answer that
question
i care about the truth so so basic truth
matters i want to live in a society
where people care about the truth and
we're grounded in truth um i care about
children and this these insane ideas
about gender are being are being foist
on kids
um and that that bothers me quite a bit
i care about the women who are having
their opportunities stolen from them i
care quite a bit yeah
now another point i didn't have the
chance to make there is that um is that
sh
she wants me to care she says why do you
care well i could have said because you
want me to
the other two people on the stage they
want me to care also
their whole job is to go around
insisting that everybody care about this
issue
these people march in literal parades
with banners and floats screaming into
bull horns that we all should care
it's just that they want me to care in
only a very specific way
and to draw very specific conclusions
so when she says why do you care so much
what she really means is
why has your concern about this issue
led you to conclusions that i disapprove
of
and so i gave her the answer it's
important to always emphasize that our
first concern
is not fairness it's not sports it's not
privacy it's not even safety those are
all concerns and they're important but
our primary motivation
is to defend truth
for its own sake
if there was a serious campaign to
convince everyone
that squares are circles
i'd be arguing almost as passionately
against it i'd even go on dr phil
to talk about shapes it's not because i
woke up one morning feeling very
passionate about geometry
i didn't choose the fight they're the
ones who decided to wage an assault on
this basic truth and so i can choose to
either surrender the ground to them
or defend it i don't want to live in a
world where people don't know the
difference between squares and circles i
also don't want to live in a world where
people don't know the difference
between men and women
and it really is as simple as that and
as i said we should keep it simple
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
there's no better time than right now to
start saving yourself some big money
each month and it really isn't difficult
to make it happen just refinance your
mortgage and do it now before rates get
any higher
i've been talking about this a lot
lately but only because it's important
for you to know and also i just really
enjoy talking about it as well the rates
we're seeing can make a significant
impact on your budget making now the
time to call american financing it could
mean up to a thousand dollars in monthly
savings and it doesn't cost you anything
to learn more that's right they'll give
you a free mortgage review so you can
learn about custom loan options before
moving forward there's no pressure
there's no upfront or hidden fees you
could even skip up to a skip up to two
payments and you may close in as fast as
10 days
but you got a call 866 569 4711 that's
866 569 4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334nmlsconsumeraccess.org
all right um thankfully we are in studio
today i got you know i got a text from
um
from sean last night our producer saying
the offices might be closed again
because there was uh going to be some
ice this morning and uh because it
rained a little bit
and and we would have some ice on the
roads
and you know we closed down last week
for that same reason because there was
just like some ice
fortunately it didn't end up happening
we are here but i was just thinking man
like why is everyone so petrified of ice
why would we even consider shutting down
just drive slower and everything will be
fine then i remember and i have these
moments sometimes here where i remember
um
that i'm working with a bunch of
californians
and uh these la people that come across
a frozen puddle and they they call the
fire department they don't know what to
do
but then i also thought about the fact
that they're from los angeles back in
the old studio they they were going to
work every day in the middle of a
crime-ridden
uh
walking dead wasteland they were
navigating through like mad max every
day they'd have knife-wielding meth
addicts chasing them through the parking
lot
but a little bit of ice scares them i
don't quite understand
but fortunately we are here
and now i guess we'll get it's a kind of
a sore subject but um biden as mentioned
did have his press conference
yesterday timing it exactly is that is
it is it a coincidence
that the one president only second press
conference he gives in a year happens to
air at the same time as my dr phil
appearance coincidence
probably but
maybe not
um
he uh so we'll go through a couple of
his answers here
he's asked about why he um
called most of the country jim crow
racist and um
you know is he is he a very angry man
who hates
most of the citizens of this country is
that why
his answer doesn't do much to allay
those
that suspicion let's listen
you campaigned and you ran on a return
to civility and i know that you dispute
the characterization that you called
folks who would oppose those voting
bills um as being bull connor or george
wallace but you said that they would be
sort of in the same camp no i didn't say
that look what i said go back and read
what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
so did you expect that that would work
with senators mansion or or cinema now
here's the thing there's certain things
that are so consequential you have to
speak from your heart as well as your
head
i was speaking out
forcefully on what i think to be at
stake
that's what it is and by the way
no one
no one forgets who was on the side of
king or verse on or bulcan
no one not done that the history books
will note it was making the case don't
think this is a freebie
you don't get to vote this way and then
somehow it goes away this will be stick
with you the rest of your career and
long after you're gone
what a disaster um
you know our our
enemies
watch
this
and they are they're licking their chops
you see this man who has clearly lost
his mind is a dementia patient
you know there's the people on the right
that complain that we don't get more
press conferences
i i i hope we don't have another one for
the rest of his presidency
i hope this is the last i i i wish that
he would never address the public ever
again
address us with a in written word you
know send it send a memo send an email
that we'll all get
because having him up i don't see how it
does anybody any good to have him losing
his mind visibly on camera
um
doesn't do us any good
unless the people who are
in a position to do it will actually
take steps
to get rid of this guy
because he's not mentally competent but
that's that's not going to happen
so i hope there's not another press
conference
two a year is too much
and uh and he said what what what even
is his justification he says i guess
it's just his rationale here is that
no no i said that you were on the side
of bull connor
and uh and george wallace i didn't say
that you were those people
that actually is a rationale come on i
didn't i didn't accuse everyone of being
bull conor i just said they were well we
know that
we know you didn't you weren't saying
they literally are that person
but you were equating them with that
person
if they won't uh support a voting rights
bill to protect the rights that
everybody already has
and speaking of voting he was also asked
about well if we don't get this voting
rights bill in place
and then we get to the midterm elections
you know okay are you willing can you
sit here and just assure everybody
assure the american people that the
elections are still legitimate
especially because we've been told
repeatedly over the last year year and a
half
that the worst thing you could ever do
is question the legitimacy of our
elections that is an attack on our very
democracy our system of government
it's an attack on our society
let's see how uh joe biden fields that
question
speaking of voting rights legislation if
this isn't passed do you still believe
the upcoming election will be fairly
conducted and its results will be
legitimate
well it all depends on uh
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
okay so in other words if i don't get my
way then yes the elections are
illegitimate
and it's just uh it's just a a
coincidence but so you understand all
this is a coincidence the fact that they
are almost certainly going to going to
be annihilated in the midterms the
democrats are walking into a bloodbath
and there's no escaping it now and they
know it
and the fact that that's about to happen
and now is when they're launching
this full-on campaign
screaming about an attack on voting
rights and people are being prevented
from voting
all the coincidence right
no this is well i'll tell you what it's
not this is not as i've explained many
times this is not a double standard it
sounds like a double standard
when you hear him the president united
states standing in front of the american
people and openly
and in advance questioning the
legitimacy and therefore the results of
an upcoming election
when you hear him doing that
after he and the rest of democrats spent
the last year condemning trump for doing
something similar
you might say that's a double standard
it's not a double standard
there is one standard here
and the one standard again is it's okay
when they do it
whatever maybe we'll put it this way
whatever they are doing is okay
because it's them
and whatever their opponents are doing
is bad
because they're the opponents that's the
standard
there's a certain um
coherence to it not really there's no
moral coherence but it's at least
understandable
that's that's all it is one standard
they can do it but not you
that's the case when it comes to
questioning elections that's the case
when it comes to
attending a maskless
party
they can do it but not you
all right i remember yesterday how don
lemon said that we should not do our own
research like idiots only an idiot would
try to do their own research and look
things up and read
no just listen to them we should just
trust them
well okay then um then i guess if we
should trust them then we should
probably trust this report from npr and
repeat it on every
major news show corporate media news
show on the left especially in msnbc
here's the report from msnbc and we have
to trust it
because if you're doing your own
research remember then then you're an
idiot and uh and you're you're lost
you're a lost case listen to them they
would never lie to us
tragically anti-mass insanity has now
reached the highest court in the land
that's based on brand new reporting
today from npr which reveals new fishers
opening up among the justices during one
of the most consequential years for the
court in recent history the reporting
zeros in on a jarring site earlier this
month when the justices took the bench
at the height of the omicron surge all
of them wearing masks except for justice
neil gorsuch justice sotomayor who
instead participated remotely from
chambers the npr report explains quote
sotomayor has diabetes a condition that
puts her at high risk for serious
illness or even death from coven 19 and
she did not feel safe in close proximity
to people who were unmasked chief
justice john roberts understanding that
in some form asked the other justices to
mask up
they all did except gorsuch
so neil gorsuch refused to mask up even
though he was instructed to and then
sotomayor wouldn't come and and wouldn't
be there in person because of it
now i heard this report
and uh my first thought was
you know if that's true
good for neil gorsuch i didn't have a
problem with it
um
i mean
do you not trust the vaccine
so am i yours vaccinated i assume triple
vaccinated if not quadruple vaccinated
at this point
and so all the people giving gorsuch a
hard time based on this report sounds to
me like they're questioning the efficacy
of the vaccine they all need to be
banned from twitter
you know
because if you trust the vaccine then
then then what's what's what's the
problem she's protected
unless you don't think that the
protection is
good enough
joy reid on msnbc she was especially
upset about this and she came out pretty
hard and she's just defending
sotomayor from from the nasty neil
gorsuch listen to this
not gorsuch he could not be bothered to
extend the life-saving courtesy to his
co-worker
and it is as serious as life and death
because diabetes is a huge risk factor a
report last summer found that 40 percent
of people who died from covet 19 had
diabetes there's a chance that those
numbers might look different with
vaccination and omicron but the cdc
still lists diabetes as a condition
where people are more likely to get
severely ill
so for having zero zero problem risking
the life of your colleague because you
just don't feel like putting a mask on
you neil gorsuch are both a rotten
co-worker dangerous to be near in a
pandemic and tonight's absolute worst
you're the absolute worst neil gorsuch
well one little problem here just one
this is a slight kind of a slight
problem technical detail is that um all
of that is is nonsense none of that is
true now the update from cnbc it says
supreme court justice sonas sonia
sotomayor and neil gorsuch on wednesday
denied that their relationship had been
frayed over a disagreement about wearing
masks as a cove 19 safety measure
the rare joint statement from the two
sitting justices came one day after an
npr report said that ghost gorsuch
refused to wear the mask
and here's what their statement says
reporting that justice sotomayor asked
justice gorsuch to wear a mask surprised
us it is false
while we may sometimes disagree about
the law we are warm colleagues and
friends
and then we have another denial this is
from the new york post supreme court
justice john roberts issued a statement
wednesday denying a national publicly
radio report about this
and he said quote i did not request
justice gorsuch or any justice to wear a
mask on the bench
so you can believe uh the corporate
media or you can believe the actual
people involved all of whom have come
out this is pretty pretty rare for
supreme court justices to respond to
media reports and all that kind of stuff
so this is one where they're coming down
and coming out and saying totally untrue
so this brings us back to yesterday it's
a don lemon's point
about how you shouldn't be doing your
own research
well if you're interested in knowing
what's happening in the world what else
are you supposed to do
again
it admitting
all of the hazards that are inherent
when you try to
just wander into the wilds of the
internet to try to learn anything
there are plenty of hazards there
and many different ways you can be led
astray
and certainly many different
distractions
that can take you off task
it's not ideal
right
but um
there are people there are institutions
in this country that are tasked with
delivering the truth and letting us know
what's happening and we cannot trust
them
it's as simple as that
all right
so um audi is uh taking a courageous
stand for diversity
so let's uh they put this out first
let's look at the tweet from uh from
audi do we have the photo says progress
in the workplace diversity and inclusion
play a key role in any team dynamic
therefore audi has introduced gender
sensitive language in doing so we open
the door to more diversity of
perspective the ability to change and to
learn now
i speaking of researching on the
internet i did i i spent you know as
much time as i could stomachs as about
45 seconds trying to figure out what
this even means
audi has introduced gender sensitive
language in
in what context what do you mean you've
introduced it hey everybody i'd like to
introduce you some gender sense of
language here it is
good for you
did they just post a list of gender
sensitive words
hoping for a round of applause
not hard to get a round of applause like
i learned on dr phil
so this is what they posted and then
they followed it up with a um
with uh
a commercial i don't know what we call
this but let's uh let's play this and i
guess i'll have to narrate a little
because it's most mostly uh mostly words
but here is audi's
woke commercial
advertising their
sensitivity
here it is
because we recently introduced gender
sensitive language
okay still not clear what the gen what
what this means
causing strong and sometimes rejecting
reactions
then we get a
now they're putting up just random
twitter accounts who are saying this is
bad we don't like political correctness
they say we respect all opinions but our
position towards diversity and inclusion
is clear
and then there's a rainbow flag
and an audi car with a rainbow an audi
diversity stands for pluralism
and then just random people we believe
in different ways of thinking
like all those people are all thinking
we're convinced that open and
unprejudiced cooperation makes us
stronger what does any of this have to
do with cars
and there we go in our view gender
inclusive language
is what is a positive attitude toward
diversity and equity what
all right
and we're not the only ones
well now we're getting tweets from
people cheering them on
look at all these random accounts that
said we're good
well nice job audi all right turn this
off
what was that
gender inclusive language is a positive
attitude towards diversity and inclusion
that those
that's just a series of leftist buzz
phrases
and terms
thrown out it's like scrabble you just
threw them out on the board
throw them into a blender blend it
together pour out the smoothie of a of
meaningless lingo that doesn't even mean
anything
gender sensitive language is a positive
attitude towards diversity and inclusion
i saw someone on twitter say that they
really appreciate it when their luxury
vehicles uh lecture them and i think
that that kind of sums it up
isn't this what we all desire
we want to be lectured by audi and we
also
i think i can speak for everybody when i
say this that um
we look to
[Music]
car manufacturers
to to point us the way forward and to
tell us
what sort of people we should be i think
we look to them for moral guidance do we
not
fantastic let's get now to the comment
section
do you know their name
all right uh let's start of course we
have our uh
fancy
video comments now and you can leave you
can submit your own video comment by
going to
dailywire.com
sweet baby comments i think that's the
correct one
i want to jump ahead too let's play clip
11.
listen to this comment
hi matt my name is salaam and i'm a
syrian citizen who was granted asylum in
the united states
going back to your point about why the
lady should take on her husband's last
name
you summed up your argument
in one word tradition i would say it's
more than just tradition i mean it's the
same way in my country too
the reason why
the man's last name should be the
family's last name is that
we need to connect the man to his kids
and vice versa we know
we always know them who the mother is
but we don't always know who the father
is especially in the case of children
born out of wedlock
our connection to our mothers is
physical
while our connection to our father is
spiritual therefore we need to connect
the father to their kids and uh sbg for
life
yeah i think that's a good point um
first of all stop arguing with me second
really good point and i i think that i
think that's right
i i also think this is not mutually
exclusive
right because i said that um that this
is
one of the reasons why the woman takes a
man's name is because of tradition
and what you're providing is one of the
reasons why that tradition is there in
the first place so
that's one layer deeper i don't think
these are mutually exclusive things but
i did want to emphasize the tradition
because i think it matters and i don't
want to give the impression that there's
something embarrassing or flimsy about
arguing in favor of something based on
the fact that it's a tradition
um people are hesitant to do that these
days because we have this idea that's
just a tradition who cares about that
like traditions are inherently
um dispensable i know that's not your
position but that's that is a position
that lots of people hold and so i think
there's there's a value in in saying no
this is good
in large part because it's tradition
tradition is is the democracy of the
dead as chesterton said
it connects us to our ancestors just as
the name connects the father to his
children
it connects us to our past and and uh
therefore connects us to ourselves
in a certain way
you're listening to the wisdom of the
billions who lived before you
um and
there's nothing wrong with asking oh
well this is a tradition this is what
our ancestors did this is where their
wisdom led them
um this was their lived experience
to use the another to using my own buzz
word there
there's nothing wrong with asking well
you know why why was that a tradition
why
what was the reason for it
and then that's where we get to some of
the answers just given there um in the
comment
but
going to another chesterton point
um
that you know if you come across
a fence
as you're walking along and you see a
fence there
and you don't know why the fence is put
there it would be a very stupid thing to
just tear it down
because you don't know why it's there
and it's possible you could come across
a fence that should not be there and
then there's a reason to tear it down
but if you don't know why it's there the
last thing you should do is tear it down
there might be a dog on the other side
of the fence who's going to eat your
face and
same thing with traditions if you don't
understand
why the tradition is put in place
then you shouldn't be trying to destroy
it because you don't even know why it's
there
and that's where you should fall back on
the fact you don't understand it
but billions before you
thought that this was a worthy and
worthwhile thing
so you we you have uh your ignorance
versus
the wisdom of the ages
which which which should you uh side
with the question
all right
let's take a look at um
12 clip 12.
okay
showing this this is a good
demonstration doing the right thing
so putting the shopping cart
into the cart corral look at that
you know what that is well done
well done my sweet children um
it's i could see snow on the ground snow
and ice
does that was very traumatic that that
clip for like all the people in control
room to see that from los angeles snow
and ice on the ground uh she was
traveling across that snow and ice
across the vast expanse of the parking
lot
with determination in her heart to put
that cart away
and that is true courage
i applaud it uh let's look at one more
this is uh let's play clip 13.
hello i'm grace and my pronouns are
sweet baby and sweet baby self i've been
a follower since the alpaca grooming
days
so a very long time and the first
article that i came across of yours was
kids go to college or you'll dial in a
misery so whenever you go on about the
college topic it's always a fun blast of
nostalgia
so i have a quick question
many times when i bring up two family or
friends that i'm a fan of yours they
claim that
you are quote unquote rude i would never
say such a thing of course but some
people do make this heinous claim and
they say that that is not fitting
for a christian
and i'm curious what you would say to
these people so spg for life
well you say spg for life but are those
people still your friends
is that still family do you still see
your family that says that about me
because then because if so i'm
questioning your spg credentials but to
answer like to answer the question i
have heard that a time or two
that i'm a bad christian because of my
attitude and my demeanor i'll say a few
things about that first of all this idea
that christians are all called to be
mild and polite and meek
is a totally incoherent from a
scriptural standpoint i mean the bible
is chock-full of people who were
extremely aggressive
and blunt and angry and even rude
sometimes um
that's all over the bible in both
testaments not just the old testament
but i mean especially the old testament
go to the new testament read the letters
of paul sometime
you know he was not uh putting up with
with nonsense from anybody
jesus
is not depicted as the sort of mr rogers
figure that he's made out to be today he
was quite
um shall we say discourteous at times uh
abrupt
when dealing with the pharisees and so
on especially with anyone who was
engaging with him in a dishonest or bad
faith kind of way
um
so that's first thing another another
point is that you know it takes all
kinds right so you need people
well you need people like like me right
i mean i'm gonna rush in there like a
bull in a china shop and you need people
that are willing to do that who will
play that role you also need people who
are more diplomatic and nicer and more
polite i think you need all of that um
think of it like in terms of an actual
army not everyone is going to do the
same job not everyone has the same role
not everybody's getting their boots
muddy to the same extent but you need
you need all of that in terms of
personalities and approaches and
attitudes and tones and all of that so
this this debate about what's the what's
the appropriate
attitude what's the appropriate tone
what's the appropriate uh personality
for a christian to have to me is
completely absurd and and final point
although i just said that it takes all
kinds
personality-wise
there are times in history
when certain kinds are needed more than
others
and we're at a point right now
where we are facing the total moral and
intellectual collapse of civilization
that's what we're up against
and it's a very noisy process also
there's lots of noise and distraction
you need to shout above the noise to be
heard
to begin with
gentle meek whispering isn't going to
cut it no one's going to hear you or
care
there might be a time for that but it's
not really right now we're teetering on
the edge
there is a there's an urgency
that we should feel it's an emergency
so it's a time for a more aggressive and
direct approach
and we certainly can't afford to be to
be tone policing at a moment like this
i mean this is what trips me up the most
is that
civilization is collapsing
the church in the west is collapsing as
well all around us
and you still have some christians who
are
you know pointing at other people and
saying i don't know he's a little bit
rude
you know it's don't be so rude
that's what you're worried about that's
it
they just criminalized christianity and
in canada in effect
it's going to happen here next and
you're concerned that i might be too
rude
my god
um all right a couple of the uh written
comments also this is from rosemary says
it's not almost everyone in the country
who knows this trans stuff is insane
everyone knows this including its
advocates
they just don't care the false ideology
comes above all else for them
um i think it is almost everyone i do
think there are some people who
because of uh delusion or mental illness
like i said on dr phil
really are confused
and then there are kids who are
indoctrinated into this and the
confusion is cultivated in a very
intentional sort of way
and uh and they don't no they don't know
anything they're they're totally
confused
but i think especially when we're
dealing with adults
people who have been on this earth for
more than
you know 20 years
and who at the very least grew up in a
world where
everybody knew
that men are men and women are women for
all of them yeah i think they all know
but the false ideology comes above all
else as you said
um
class of 79 says matt i agree that
phelps is a coward but saying he has
nothing to lose is simply not true his
sponsors would drop him like a bad habit
if he strongly opposed a trans swimmer
he's self-interested like any of these
elites who want to protect their bottom
line
um yeah i guess i should have said it
would cost them in effect nothing
right
uh yeah he he would lose some
sponsorships and all that but he's
already filthy rich
and he's not gonna be we don't have to
worry phelps doesn't have to worry about
ending up uh homeless on the street it's
not gonna happen to him
and the other thing is even if he were
dropped by sponsors
there would be
a lot of other financial support coming
his way
there are plenty of other sponsors out
there that would love to support him if
he took a stand for sanity
and then he was canceled right
we give him a job here at the daily wire
i don't know doing what exactly but
we would do that
and um
finally porchside politics says matt's
sweet calm condescending attitude is the
best
sweet sweet calm and condescending all
right well there you go like i said it
takes all kinds
tonight at 8 pm eastern 7 pm central ben
shapiro kicks off his new book club with
his first all-access discussion and
tonight's book selection is orwell's
famous 1984 quite timely and topical for
his book club each month ben will
recommend a notable classic to dive into
daily wire members can get ben's
personal notes to follow along with the
book at the third
thursdaybookclub.com again it's third
thursdaybookclub.com then on the third
thursday of each month ben joins
dailywire all access members online for
an in-depth lecture and discussion of
each book where you can ask him
questions directly and right now get 25
off all daily wire memberships with code
1984 over at dailywire.com
subscribe members join ben tonight at 8
pm eastern 7 pm central at dailywire.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
our cancellation brings us in a circle
much like the logic of my opponents on
dr phil
one of those opponents addison rose
vincent who's the one with the beard
posted a story to instagram shortly
before the episode aired yesterday
addison is not pleased
the post explains quote about a month
ago ethan and i were invited to be
guests on the dr phil show to share our
stories and discuss pronouns we were
excited for the opportunity to educate
in a safe space
so you see here by the way that they
were not looking for a debate they they
were there to educate
and that means that they speak and the
rest of us shut up and listen that's not
exactly how it worked out for them and
now they're traumatized
back to the post
what ended up happening was much
different than we discussed than they
discussed with us and we left feeling
attacked by another guest and played by
the producers well the other guest
sounds like a jerk i mean i
can't believe he would do that addison
continues the episode airs today and
we're very worried about how the whole
thing will be edited if you want to
watch go for it but it may be
uncomfortable or triggering to do so
since the taping ethan and i have been
experiencing a heightened level of
anxiety to the point that we've had
numerous nightmares and depression
spirals over the last month this week
has been the worst
please send us both good vibes today we
could really use it
we tried our best with no preparation
for what the dr phil show actually had
planned behind our backs
and we hope our visibility inspires
viewers viewers
well addison
it inspired me
and i hope you can take some solace in
that
now for the record they these people
were not tricked or fooled by the
producers we all had exactly the same
amount of information going in we knew
it would be a panel with people on both
sides of the issue that's all i knew
that's all anybody knew as for the
editing the editors did the trans
propaganda side a number of favors
now i'm not going to claim that that it
was motivated by bias dr phil's team was
really fair to everybody i thought
but um things get cut for time
inevitably and so we all had big chunks
taken out i know that i did
and the more that they cut from the
addison side of it and that team the
better for them
because they only sounded more and more
deranged as the episode went on
so as bad as they sounded i can tell you
right now
it was much worse
in in real time
so what are addison and ethan the poor
deers really upset about
they knew they'd be facing off with
people who disagree with them
they also talk about these issues every
single day for a living
it's their job to go around promoting
this stuff
so wha
why did i traumatize them how
why am i now haunting their dreams
i mean this is me we're talking about
i'm a cuddly
nice and lovable guy
the answer is that our culture has so
effectively scared the same people into
silence that these propagandists have
been running essentially unopposed this
whole time
they've never run into any pushback
they've never encountered any friction
nobody has ever called them out on their
nonsense ever
for a lot of them
they've been so ensconced in their
bubble so comfortable in their
protective cocoon that it never even
occurred to them that anybody that
anybody would come on national
television and actually challenge their
position
the possibility was literally
unthinkable
they knew there'd be some kind of token
opposition some patsies brought up there
to represent some sanitized
approximation of the other side but they
expected that conversation to be rigged
in their favor
because it always is everywhere all the
time
now they still got a little bit of that
later in the episode two parents were
invited on to talk about their efforts
to keep this pronoun crap out of the
children's out of their children's
schools
and both of these parents are doing
important work and they're brave for
taking a stand and i commend them
but one of them began
i think with a mistake
by laying an offering at the feet of the
trans agenda watch this
first of all thank you for having me and
i wanted to say it's so i honor you and
your journey and where you are in life
and i it has nothing to do with that
it's we're here about our kids
and um so in school
i feel like this is a family issue it's
a parent child issue and it's a real
issue with some kids i think that the
percentage is quite small
for how many kids go through this real
serious issue
and including and imposing this on the
entire school or the entire class is
where i have a problem
okay so that's exactly what addison and
ethan expected
that's what they want and demand and
require
they'll tolerate mild disagreement
if only for appearances sake
but you better be giving those
criticisms on your knees and apologizing
in advance for everything you say
i honor you she said
well addison and ethan i do not honor
you
i think you're completely wrong about
everything you say what's more i think
you're narcissists and bullies
i think you don't give a damn about
anybody or anything but yourselves
i think you advocate for opening up
bathrooms and sports teams because from
your perspective the rape trauma and
abuse that happens as a result is worth
it
as long as your ideology wins the day
and your self-perceptions are reinforced
because that's all you care about
i think you represent something that is
not only anti-scientific and irrational
but evil
and i think you have evil intentions
i think you're bad people
and i think that you are neither correct
nor well-meaning
and if one person in the whole world in
your whole life
saying this to you causes you to spiral
into depression and be plagued by
nightmares
maybe that should clue you in
it sounds like your conscience is trying
to tell you something
you see people scream at me every day
and they say the most horrible things
about myself and my family
i encounter more outright hostility in a
day
than you have in your whole life i
guarantee you that
i don't i didn't have the audience
clapping for me
you do
and yet i've slept like a baby every
night since that taping
that's because i know i'm standing in
the truth not just factually but morally
you don't have the same self-assurance
well
then maybe you should look within
yourself that's all you ever do anyway
you're constantly staring back into
yourself shouting into the cavern of
your own ego listening to the echo
well while you're in there
maybe try a bit of actual introspection
it might serve you well
in the meantime
and i'm sorry if this gives you even
more nightmares
but sadly you are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show in his
first press conference in months joe
biden celebrates his successes questions
election integrity and gives the green
light to vladimir putin to invade
ukraine so that's great that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen